there have been plenty of intriguing
sound bites all week you heard from
brian goody koontz earlier in the week
aaron rodgers will be the packers
quarterback for the foreseeable future
and as i pointed out if we're all going
to be dead by sunday potentially the
foreseeable future may not be all that
far off after all here's how it got
started
first
was the report that traces back to our
good friend paul allen voice of the
vikings
who heard from a very reliable source
based upon what i've been able to gather
and i've talked to many people
throughout the course of the day
he caught wind of this effort by the
49ers
to trade for aaron rodgers now i didn't
know when it happened i put on my
hat with the little sign in it that says
reporter and i found out it was last
night
that that offer was made by the 49ers to
the packers and rejected by the packers
and obviously aaron wanted it to go
through 49ers wouldn't have bothered if
they didn't think that aaron would
embrace the possibility rogers wanted to
go through it didn't go through shereen
that was the first domino that was just
six hours ago the world has changed
dramatically since then let's just look
at this before we get down the aaron
rodgers wormhole
the fact that the 49ers gave up what
they gave up to move all the way to
number three and they're supposedly set
on what they're going to do with the
third overall pick the fact that they
would try to flip that last night for
aaron rodgers either speaks to genius or
idiocy i don't know that there's a
middle ground
no that's exactly right mike and i
i think they dr traded up to draft a
quarterback but then they thought this
might have become possible i don't know
you know it almost seems like the 49ers
have completely botched this thing from
the start and maybe they haven't maybe
they've known all along who they're
gonna be i don't know how it's gonna
work out it'd be interesting to see what
they say when this thing is done
but if they actually traded up to try
and get aaron rodgers and could get him
i think it would be genius now i don't
think they get him i don't think the
packers would trade him to the 49ers i
don't think they're going to trade him
to an nfc team when they trade him and i
do think this is a win case not an if
case when they try to trade him i think
it's going to be to an afc team and not
an nfc team mike but intriguing that
they would offer the number three pick
and more for aaron rodgers last night
jimmy garoppolo was part of the package
obviously you can't get that deal done
unless garoppolo takes last money the
packers aren't taking on his 25 million
salary for jimmy garoppolo so that was
dead on arrival and
the packers i'm told don't feel
compelled to get a quarterback out of
this transaction they're ready to turn
to jordan love if they do move on from
aaron rodgers and my understanding is
and this isn't 100
in concrete but i think the packers
would have taken kyle pitts the florida
tight end if they had emerged with a
third overall pick in the draft so you'd
have pits you'd have love you'd have
devonte adams you'd have the running
back whose name for some reason his
escapement aaron jones how can i forget
aaron jones it's too crazy of a day
aaron rodgers aaron jones they know who
we mean regardless that's how it got
started so
that is what sparked
the frenzy by reporters to add to the
story because that's how the game works
big story lands
it creates an aftershock and then
another earthquake comes after it
shireen and yeah
one last point on the 49ers because this
really does seem dysfunctional to me and
again maybe it's functioning at a a
level so high i don't get it we'll get
back to that let's focus on rogers so
then the report came out that
multiple teams had called the packers
about aaron rodgers now multiple means
more than one we know that the rams
reportedly according to sam farmer
called before they traded for matthew
stafford weeks ago the packers denied it
because why would they admit it there's
a certain
must not tell the truth dynamic to some
of the things that happened in the nfl
because if you give it credence it takes
on a life of its own but that's how this
started to take on a life of its own it
goes glazer reporting multiple teams
were interested in rogers and then
schefter with the thing that really took
it to a next level that he's told people
within the organization he doesn't want
to be
with the packers he's disgruntled as
opposed to being gruntled with the
packers and wants to be traded
and that
that was the thing that like poured
the rocket fuel onto the fire and then
it went from there but that's when it
all went from the 49ers
just you know
by all appearances
catching a wild hair and taking a chance
to well this is something deeper than
the 49ers the 49ers thing was a symptom
of a deeper problem and the deeper
problem is rogers wants out
well and frankly mike i hope multiple
means 12 to 15 teams because that's how
many teams could use aaron rodgers and i
said all along i would not be in a rush
to get a quarterback if i'm in the
quarterback market because you're going
to have rogers you're going to have
wilson you're going to have desean
watson at some point become available i
want one of those guys i mean i'm not so
sure i wouldn't want an aaron rodgers
over at
trevor lawrence now we know that's not
going to happen but i'm just saying
there's no quarterback in this drive i
realize he's 37 year old 37 years old i
get that but if i am a team that's
willing to win i want aaron rodgers it's
like the bucks last year i feel like
he's the one part that can put me over
the top get me to a super bowl perhaps
win multiple super bowls he was the best
quarterback in the nfc championship game
last year mike and he didn't get it done
because the buccaneers had a better team
than what he had
well
i agree to that to a certain extent this
still is a guy who only has won one
super bowl in his career and we can go
around and round on whose fault it is
but the bottom line is tom brady had six
before he went to tampa and went one for
one i don't have the same faith that you
plug aaron rodgers into a new team and
it suddenly all falls together because i
still think at some level he's partially
to blame for the fact that the packers
have not won more than one super bowl we
can say he doesn't have the help around
him but we can all we can also say he
doesn't have that transformative
capacity that tom brady does to bring a
team together and lift it to higher
levels than it otherwise would rise
without that extra influence of a
quarterback who is a gifted leader on
top of being a highly gifted passer so
so
you know
something you said there
really brings into question the tom
brady dynamic because i tweeted at one
point this afternoon how many teams
has tom brady psychologically wrecked in
the course of the last year the patriots
who are completely out of character
desperate to get better spending like
never before to be good enough to
compete with brady's buccaneers this
year when the buccaneers come to town
and to be better and more relevant in
january like brady's buccaneers will be
the seahawks russell wilson wants more
involvement in the team wants greater
say wants out if he doesn't get what he
wants and now rogers who had kept it in
check
see rogers i think was trying his
damnedest
to walk that tightrope between agitating
for something but not being perceived as
the bad guy now he's risking being
perceived as the bad guy based on
everything that's coming out today but
this is another product of the brady
factor and something you said shireen
about you know if the jaguars would
actually want aaron rodgers over trevor
lawrence the guy who possibly is an
answer for 15 years over the guy who's
an answer for four years at most it just
shows you what brady's done to mess up
the mindset of so many teams you've got
teams that are pedal to the metal win
now and will take a handful of years
with rogers over 15 years with trevor
lawrence i don't know if the jaguars
would do it but i don't think it would
be an easy question if they had the
opportunity
and it just shows you how dramatically
the game has changed and it all traces
to tom brady
no question the game changed last year
mike with brady doing what he did and
leaving the patriots and going to the
bucks and to some extent phillip rivers
leaving the chargers after so many years
and going to the colts that didn't quite
work out and i am curious if the bucks
hadn't won the super bowl this past year
would things have changed for tom brady
would he have wanted to go somewhere
else
to have a better chance to win a super
bowl because we know the tension that
might have been there mid-season when
the bucks weren't doing so great and
bruce arians is publicly criticizing tom
brady we don't know what the inner
workings of that was but the way it
played out those questions have gone
away because they won the super bowl
same thing with the packers if they had
won the super bowl over the past two
years look they went 13-3 13-3 and lost
in the title game each of the last two
seasons if they win one of those two
super bowls i think we're having a
different conversation today i think if
brady hadn't won the mvp award we're
having a different conversation today
because i think he's already traded so
so many things played out over the last
year mike that changed as you said
all these dynamics around the league of
what teams are looking for what
franchise quarterbacks are looking for
and how things have developed it's just
changed in the last year right in front
of our eyes
and back in january after the nfc
championship when the packers lost to
the buccaneers a game they could have
and should have won that's when rogers
dropped that turd into the punch bowl
and then acted like it wasn't there when
he was on pat mcafee show two days later
it was there it was there and it was
multiplying over the course of the last
three months and now we are sorry for
the graphic nature of that metaphor but
we are where we are and it's all blown
up quickly other nuggets that have come
out today
the packers decision makers traveled to
california to meet with aaron rodgers
rogers
agent met with the packers they're
trying to work out a new contract they
can't get it done
and
and hey i reported back in january
people thought i was nuts that rogers
wants a new contract he did that's part
of it it's not the root cause but the
fact that they haven't given him a
contract is just another example of why
he's frustrated with the organization
not matt lafleur the head coach but with
the organization i was told he simply
doesn't like anyone in the front office
for a variety of reasons whether that's
brian goody koontz russ ball mark murphy
i've said for weeks shireen that mark
murphy has been trying to manipulate
aaron rodgers into a sweet spot of
piss-offedness where he's mad enough
that he's going to show up and bust his
butt and be an mvp caliber player but
not so upset that he wants out well if
that's the case murphy overshot it
because now rogers is sufficiently
pissed off that he wants out
yeah that's exactly right mike but let's
back up a minute does darren rogers like
anybody we know his relationship with
his family so he has a lot of strained
relationships everywhere right
i'm leaving
shereen you take over
i can't be part of this
that was shireen williams lest there be
any
any confusion aaron rodgers and and and
i will produce my phone for inspection
by the court there was no advanced
cajoling or instigating by me to get her
to say that she blurted that out on her
own with no influence from me but but i
did uh
but uh uh i don't even know what to say
uh but
[Laughter]
he's been there a long time and there
are shades of what happened with tom
brady and bill belichick and instead of
yes
brady getting to the point where he
couldn't take any more of the coach
rogers got to the point where he can't
take any more of the front office and
after
16 years
and and i think this is
the shelf life
of
and shelf life isn't the right word this
is where the fuse meets the bomb and the
fuse was lit a year ago first night of
the draft there's a certain poetry to
the fact that this is all coming out now
there's a certain
godfather one quality
to
you know while the baby's being baptized
the leaders of the five families all get
killed it's all happening at that time
the the anniversary sort of even though
it isn't exactly one year first night of
the draft that's when rogers is
unleashing his revenge on the packers
and he's smart enough to do it shireen i
wouldn't be surprised if he's been
planning this
for months if not an entire year back to
the night that they sent him rushing to
a big bottle of tequila
oh it's a great point mike this is not a
coincidence that this was leaked today
this is maximum exposure it drives
interest it's going to overshadow the
draft no doubt about it and it's going
to encourage teams to make that call of
the packers instead of the packers
sitting in that draft room right now
thinking about who they're drafting in
the first round i guarantee you they're
getting phone calls going hey what's it
going to take to get aaron rodgers we'll
give you this this and this they are
getting those calls right now there's no
question about it if they're not these
teams are stupid not to make that phone
call again he's better than any guy in
the draft that you can get he's better
than any free agent you're going to be
able to sign next year he he's the
quarterback that you want if you're
close to winning if you're perhaps the
broncos or the raiders or one of these
teams that have been mentioned he's the
guy you want not one of these other guys
so they're being lit up right now and
it's for these reasons because aaron
rodgers and his agent have released this
information to people and it just it's
it's just going and going and going mike
this carousel is probably going to go
all night
see i don't know that they
deliberately planted the first piece
here but they knew it was going to come
out the 49ers effort to trade for aaron
rodgers and then once that's out then
when that's when the other stuff gets
mobilized and it takes on a life of its
own and it doesn't look like aaron
rodgers is the one
either directly or through his agents
who caused this thing to take off but
but that's where it currently is
another reporter just texted me i'm
giddy that this is all finally coming
out because some of us have known it's
there and
what's always irritated me is aaron
rodgers wants to have his cake and eat
it too he wants to be upset he wants to
be manipulative he wants to be petty he
wants to be vindictive in a very passive
aggressive way that has no footprints
and then when people see the footprints
they're the buttholes for seeing the
footprints that he put in the sand and
pointing them out and i'm i am glad this
is all coming out because it's been
there and no matter how hard he's tried
to deny it he's at the point where he
can't take it anymore so now serene
this is the the next spin it forward
where does he get traded you alluded to
this earlier okay here's my
understanding here are the key factors
number one number one packers are not
going to trade him to an nfc team brett
favre of 2008 what did they do they
traded him to the jets what was in that
jets trade
paperwork a clause that said if the jets
traded him back to the nfc north three
first round picks became the
compensation so he's going to an afc
team most likely second west coast team
or close to it that's what aaron rodgers
wants now
if if his options completely dry up
would he go farther east than green bay
currently is if he wants out he may have
no choice but west coast is the
preference and as i said earlier the
packers don't need and don't necessarily
want a quarterback in return
so so
the three teams that were on his wish
list as of last night i'm told
impeccable source not to be confused
with our usual you know guy who just
happened to hang around and overhear
someone talk about it the bus station
49ers
raiders
broncos and
uh
i
if i had to throw a dart and guess i'd
say if the broncos want to make the move
if the broncos want to do it and rogers
is only a year older than peyton manning
was when they signed him in 2012 as
damaged goods and rogers isn't damaged
goods they could get four or five years
out of aaron rodgers the question is do
george payton the gm of the broncos want
to do it well peyton comes from
minnesota where he knows very well what
aaron rodgers can do he saw week one in
his own building last year roger
shredded the vikings so it's raiders
broncos unless the 49ers can come up
with something before they use that
third overall pick tonight to get a deal
done with green bay which which rogers
would welcome he'd welcome a trip home
to the bay area i think the raiders and
the broncos are the other two teams to
watch
yeah and and my you know what i would
love to see it'll never happen but i
would love to see straight up a russell
wilson for for aaron rodgers trade i
would love to see that that would be
fantastic we're never going to see it
but i think it would be great to see
what each of those guys could do on the
other team how good could those teams be
and they've both been very good teams
they both won super bowls so it would be
exciting to me to see that's not going
to happen so the team's mentioned
let me ask you this do you think you
talked about this a little bit that you
don't think that he is going to be like
brady and automatically go somewhere and
upgrade them do the broncos and raiders
give aaron rodgers a better chance to
win a super bowl than the packers do
right now as we sit here
well he's got to deal with patrick
mahomes i tweeted this earlier bad news
it looks like we could miss out again
on an aaron rodgers patrick mahomes game
because they're due to play this year
that is game not 17th game played but
the 17th extra game it is packers and
chiefs we can miss out on that but we
could pick up on two
rogers mahomes games if he lands in the
afc west
with the raiders or the broncos and
patrick mahomes said well i see draft
weekend is going to get pretty
interesting it's going to be very
interesting if he ends up playing for
las vegas or denver and
i hey
i don't
if i'm aaron rodgers that's not where i
want to go if i'm aaron rodgers i'm
going to stay in the nfc if i'm aaron
rodgers i want the 49ers i i think i
have a better chance to win a super bowl
if i don't have to compete directly with
patrick holmes but you know what if you
go to san francisco you're competing
with matthew stafford although that's
been no issue for aaron rodgers over the
last decade all due respect you're
competing with russell wilson which has
been an issue from time to time for
aaron rodgers and you got to deal with
kyle murray so uh either west
is going to be a challenge
but uh
i i just think aaron rodgers at this
point would welcome that because he's
tried it over and over again to get
another super bowl with the green bay
packers they haven't given him enough
help and he's emboldened by this tom
brady phenomenon to get to a place
where he won't be treated like an
employee that that's what it all comes
down to
are you going to treat your franchise
quarterback like an employee we talked
about this earlier in the week as it
relates to kyle murray are you treating
him like an employee or are you treating
him like a member of management and i
feel like the packers have been too far
on the treat rogers liken employee scale
and the fact that they drafted his
replacement last year when they were a
super bowl ready team they could have
used that first round pick and the
fourth round pick they packaged with it
to go up and get jordan love to get two
pieces that could have been the
difference makers
in the nfc championship game a
difference maker like antoine winfield
was
for the buccaneers in the postseason a
rookie who comes in and makes a
difference right away we'll never know
because they
wasted those two picks on someone who
did nothing to help the packers get to
the super bowl last year so i think that
that's one of the big reasons it's a
culmination of years and years of actual
or perceived disrespect and he's done
the the bridge has been crossed and now
the question is sharing if they don't
trade him what's he going to do he's
going to show up
is this another deshaun watson
is this desean watson
four months after deshaun watson made
his power play could be
could be if they don't trade that could
be
well and he also has potentially mike
jeopardy hanging out there he could just
retire and say i'm not going to show up
i'm just going to go be the host of
jeopardy you can trade me or you can
keep me and i'm not going to play for
you what are the packers going to do
then they're going to have to trade him
so if he's made it clear today that he
doesn't want to make play with the
packers if he's told the packers that
their best move today is to trade aaron
rodgers the best deal they can get and
move on from aaron rodgers and hand it
to jordan love i mean that's been the
plan all along right they were going to
hand this thing to jordan love it's the
reason they traded up to draft jordan
love last year to hand him the baton and
say hey you're our next aaron rodgers
who took over for brett favre so do it
go trade him hand it to to jordan love
and move on and get all the pics you can
get this could be your herschel walker
type deal trading him somewhere else and
getting a ton of pics and upgrading your
talent and you can
if you think you can go win with jordan
love go win with jordan love who cares
if aaron rodgers is in the nfc or
wherever he is trade him to the best
place that'll give you the most
compensation and move on from him
and
see sims and i have been talking about
this i thought and i think sims thought
that aaron rodgers was going to wait
until after this season
to implement that
plan
and i
i think he's stewed
and simmered
and percolated
and i don't know if this is a grand plan
or it just kind of happened when he
didn't get
the contract that he wanted i i just i
think
there's a deeper issue that could have
been resolved and the contract that he
wanted would have resolved it the
contract that forced the two sides
together for the next three years and
maybe they trade jordan love you know
there have been flashes of that maybe
the packers trade jordan love maybe the
packers trade jordan love it was never
really reported but there was enough
noise enough chatter
that maybe that would have been the
alternative if they decide we're going
all in with aaron rodgers we're going to
move on from jordan love we're going to
declare rogers the victor and we're
going to renew our vows with him if they
would have done that everything would be
fine but they didn't and they haven't
and rogers as we get to the first night
of the draft the first draft since they
traded up for jordan love
here here comes some game of thrones
stuff i was comparing it to the
godfather this this may be more like uh
the the dragons uh going uh going crazy
on green bay
yeah mike mikey and you you go back a
year ago i mean right this this is when
it all started and it doesn't sound like
to me they communicated with aaron
rodgers very well when they decided to
pick jordan love and that's what it goes
back to that's that's when this all
started really
and not winning a super bowl on top of
that just kind of compiled and brady
winning the championship and everything
that's happened in between then not
getting the contract and no one looking
over your shoulder as the mvp and seeing
jordan love standing there so all those
things happen mike and this just seemed
like the end now to me and i'm with sims
i i really thought he was going to play
one more year i was convinced that he
and russell wilson both would play one
more year and then you would get the the
three quarterbacks traded and and like i
said i thought the teams were going to
have some regret that have traded for
quarterbacks and drafted quarterbacks
this year they could have regrets not in
getting in on the rogers trade a russell
wilson trade and a desean watson trade
because all of those guys could become
available over the next few months and
so i think some of these teams are going
to have regret that they didn't get in
on some of these trades you look at a
team like the rams if matthew stafford
doesn't get it done they're going to
have some great regret that they traded
for matthew stafford so early and didn't
let this thing play out
you mentioned earlier the possibility of
aaron rodgers for russell wilson and i
think you could do that straight up i
think you could i think that balance is
out
if anything maybe the packers would have
to add a little more to it i don't know
i right now let's just say it balances
my point is this john schneider the gm
of the seahawks is a packers shareholder
at one point it was believed he was
going to end up back in green bay as the
general manager
if
he's concerned
that rogers could end up with the 49ers
don't you at least have the conversation
internally
about
mobilizing
about
russell wilson to green bay for aaron
rodgers now again the packers want to go
to jordan love
but if russell wilson falls into your
lap
the jordan love plan gets put on hold
because you didn't know you were going
to get russell wilson so i can't rule
that out either now it's not on roger's
wish list because it isn't as easy of a
landing spot as it would be
in san francisco or denver it's a little
bumpier in las vegas because derek carr
is there but derek carr is not russell
wilson i can see why the seahawks
wouldn't have been on aaron rodgers wish
list because you just assume
too complicated to make it happen but
maybe not at this point
maybe john schneider says hey i'd rather
deal
with aaron rodgers on my team than deal
with aaron rodgers on the 49ers and if
this russell wilson thing is going to
blow up anyway
let's get let's get four years out of
rogers because all we were going to get
was one more year at most out of russell
wilson so i i just
i can't imagine schneider not at least
exploring the possibility making a phone
call to somebody in green bay and having
the conversation to see if they can work
it out uh because that's that's far
preferable to competing with aaron
rodgers in your division for the next
four years
oh absolutely mike and again i would
love to see that that would be my number
one trade i would like to see happen
where i would like sierra rogers end up
and where i would like to see russell
wilson end up because those teams have
been so good and those quarterbacks
haven't gotten them there to a super
bowl in many years so maybe if they
switch quarterbacks each of them will
have a chance to win one over the next
couple years let me ask you this though
mike what do you think the comp
throw seattle out right now if you're
broncos or raiders what's the
compensation what's it gonna take to get
aaron rodgers
well
i mean the packers said no to the third
overall pick and jimmy garoppolo and
more stuff from the 49ers again they got
no use for jimmy garoppolo he's an
albatross on this deal he's not a
sweetener by any means it's it's the
it's the jared goff in the matthew
stafford package frankly so maybe you
start by saying keep keep garoppolo we
don't want him
we'll give somebody else give us george
kittle
or someone else you know nick bosa and
the third overall pick although that may
be too much i really don't know because
we haven't crossed that bridge we've
been talking about trades as it relates
to russell wilson and deshaun watson
young guys with a lot left this is older
guy
with four years at a high level maybe
but who knows with tom brady again
another reason why tom brady has screwed
everything up it screws up our
perception of how long a quarterback can
play it screws up your assessment of
whether you want a ten-year answer or a
four-year answer and i think multiple
first-round picks
um
[Music]
i don't know that it takes three
i i think that the the main thing is
the packers have to get through the five
stages of grief fairly quickly and get
to acceptance you know this is something
that may have been sprung on them for
the first time very recently and they
may be in denial right now they've
gotten through anger they're in denial
bargaining depression acceptance if they
can work through that like homer simpson
once did after he had the venom of a
poison blowfish and thought he was going
to die if they can do that quickly then
a trade can happen this weekend but they
have to be thinking about where this
goes if they don't trade him because it
very well could be aaron rodgers says
see you later green bay packers i'm out
if you don't trade me and then they got
nobody that that's that's the reality
that's the desean watson scenario before
the legal issues arose i think the
texans came to grips with the fact that
we're gonna have to trade him because
they're playing this out
we're gonna trade him and get something
in return or we're just not gonna have
this guy now at least the packers have
jordan love but still
it's better to get something in return
for aaron rodgers than to have aaron
rodgers just walk away
and the quicker this happens mike the
more they get so in other words i think
if it happens tonight they get more form
than if they wait till tomorrow the next
day or two months or three months or six
months from now i think they need to do
it tonight i'm going to put those odds
at 50 50. are you taking the over you
taking me under
50 50 of roger's being traded
yep tonight tonight under
yeah under okay but not by much not by
much
lot's got to happen a lot's got to
happen yeah i think it's more likely it
happens after tonight
and before the end of the draft for
future
first round picks i think that's
especially because the packers like many
other teams are going to value future
first round picks better because all of
a sudden you know the packers if they
trade with the broncos at nine if they
trade with the the 49ers at three i mean
they're thrust into this guys that we
haven't maybe looked at as closely as we
should have because we never thought
we'd be we'd be picking in this
stratosphere so i think that's part of
it too
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports